hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I am just checking in on you
the voice is still [__] up I got two
more record people episode 9 and number
10 where just broke number 10 we're
almost done which means old freckles is
then going to be doing a bunch of spots
around Las honglei's getting ready for
my European tour tor tor tor yeah yeah
yeah which starts off in Dublin Ireland
Dublin Ireland and you know what's funny
is I tried to get on July 31st it starts
off and I tried to get a you know get a
direct flight to the Emerald Isle and
the at this point cuz I waited so long
to get the [__] tickets you know
which is a whole other story in itself
you know what I mean because I'm going
to take a vacation with my wife
afterwards and she was trying to figure
out where the [__] we was going to go
and I was like lady you better [__]
figure out a place soon because this is
going to cost me a fortune there so
turns out out of LAX the only two
airlines it was Aer Lingus and what the
[__] is it now Jesus I already forgot
the name of the what the hell's an
Ethiopian Airlines figure that one out I
want to fly the open Airlines unless I'm
going to like you know Ethiopia Aer
Lingus that's the Irish one you know is
that weird like if I'm going to go to
the Middle East I want to fly you that
whatever United air emirate I don't it's
just weird superstition that I have like
the people at Ethiopian Airlines don't
care because they're flying that Ireland
does that make any sense it doesn't
that's just how scary flying is like if
I'm going to Poland I want a couple of
Polish guys flying it despite all the
jokes about them hey how many Polish
guys does it take to fly a plane a
[__] hopefully two of them you know
that
studied all this [__] they needed to
know so Aer Lingus was more expensive
and I said well [__] I'm going to
take the I even know if that's the Irish
one for some reason I think that's the
one with the four leaf clover is it
we've got a leprechaun on the [__]
tailfin let me look this up Aer Lingus
Latty every Irish guys giving me [__]
about my bad accent like I give a [__]
alright Aer Lingus images yeah there it
is oh it's a three leaf clover put
another [__] leaf on there you [__]
make me feel a little better
oh Jesus is that the best plane they got
oh boy that looks like some [__] from
the early 70s alright let's look at err
Ethiopia where Ethiopian Airlines
there's no food on this plane sorry
Ethiopian Airlines let's see what we got
here what have we got here I'm not gonna
lie to you both these planes that look
to be neither one of these are very uh a
little bit stewardesses they look pretty
fly debated memory stewards for the
Irish ones probably all hammered could I
have any more stereotypes in this
alright they both the professional whose
kid mode you know what it is once you
travel outside of your own country you
know what I mean I fly American Airlines
I fly United I fly [__] that I've heard
of I've always done that except early on
in my career when I used to fly like
[__] what the [__] was that one it
was air something or other I thought
look ata
I mean you flew on that [__] airline
so it was like like that the cabin to
the stuff tough cockpit was open there
what they're playing like Kinect for and
[__] it was it was really bad I'll tell
you it was bad you know not was it was
just like it was the weirdest thing
you've been in an airport and just
feeling like you were in America and
then you'd get on a TA and you literally
felt like you were leaving a war-torn
country like you're just looking around
like wait a [__] that all these extras
come from am I am I gonna mind some
[__] George Clooney
that's some important George one of
those selling arms for some [__] you
know a very important story that needed
to be tell told we are filmmakers and
this is what we do you know George they
said this script was floating around
Hollywood for a while well you know I'm
good-looking and I said I'm going to do
it so it got made
so I got a call out [__] Michael
Rapaport okay okay and you know you
would think that I'm going to call him
out for the fact that his resting face
you never heard of resting [__]
you know what his face looks like it
looks like you remember that face danny
ainge would make after he got called for
a foul that's what his resting face
looks like all right now I love this man
except what he talks sports I've never
seen somebody hate on Boston sports the
way he does right so he wrote some more
[__] about Boston sports so I call
him up breaking his balls going through
you know what you wrote isn't true
laughing we have a great [__] time he
goes on the internet like some real
housewife [__] who uh right and you
know what he said he said Wow
bill burr just called me up like
threatening me blah blah blah and all
this [__] he's out he's tweeting like
some Instagram [__] that's just trying
to get [__] follow it I don't
understand it Michael somebody send you
into this clip right now I even told
them how [__] [__] he was being
above Boston sports Rickey I guess he
was freaking out that uh that the
Celtics might get Kevin Durant which you
know whose kid no with the whole free
agency game this is how it works as a
fan everybody doesn't like it unless the
free agent comes to their team that's
basically it but at the end of the day
even when they do come via a team in the
back of your head you know it's [__]
right I mean whatever yeah you see
you're getting [__] over by your team
you want to go make some more money fine
but I'm talking when you're an elite
[__] player and you go to pile on
another [__] team and I'm talking as
a Celtics fan when we did that
at o8 the only thing that made it decent
was that the Lakers had a bunch of free
agents so we met in the finals and it
was sort of it was like the 80s in that
those two teams were in the finals
back-to-back years but I mean it was it
was [__] like I don't look at the
aged Celtics like it was a blur
we went from last place to first place
we won the [__] thing and then we
played him again next year in the finals
and the referees called nine thousand
files on us and like 15 on the [__]
Lakers and for some reason that was
considered a good game seven I don't
know but that's the NBA you know every
once in a while they have a mobbed-up
rep you know Patrick Ewing goes to the
Knicks yeah you know it's a business but
I think because I when I look at the NFL
where they got the parity there and all
of a sudden you know the Seahawks out of
[__] nowhere can win one you know
[__] Patriots stunk for [__] ever
all of a sudden we got good you go up
you go down these guys win those guys
you know it's nice and [__] everybody
kind of has a chance now and that's been
great their ratings are better than ever
as far as I know and I think the route
that the NBA is going is they create
these super teams and people hate them
so much that they watch rooting for them
to lose and I don't know I liked it
better by me back in the day like I said
there was free agency in that type of
[__] but it wasn't just the way it is
now the amount of times where people
pull the old Johnny Damon where you I
guess Damon won with the Red Sox and
then like the next year or whatever he
goes through the [__] Yankees it's
just like why Jesus Christ can you can
you ease your way around the fact that
it's just a business and it's all about
money you know I don't know I actually
don't know how Kevin Durant really helps
the Warriors in a way you know they had
that two guys that were the guys and
then he's coming in and in a lot of ways
he's at least number two depending on
what you think about the [__] the
[__] an honor roll student there
I don't know I know people say they just
want to win but I think egos get hurt
when you know you you used to get 25
points a game and now you're down to
like 21 or 19 I don't know we'll see
what the [__] happens but uh
that sucked I was really hoping he was
going to stay in Oklahoma I'm not going
to lie to you I was hoping that uh you
know after last year where they were up
three games to one that they was on the
offseason be like you know what the [__]
happened we don't know how we don't know
how to win we don't know how to close
somebody out and what I loved about
watching the Warriors come back against
Oklahoma as much as I was rooting folk
Lahoma is you got to watch a
championship team like they what the
Warriors did being down three games to
one coming back in that series
it was [__] hilarious to me like
watching them it was like remember the
horror movie like they never changed
their pace when they went down they
didn't panic they just kept coming you
know it was like those old-school
monster movies from the 80s where the
[__] Jason guy right is just walking
and the victim is running away he's the
victims running the monsters walking but
the person running keeps looking over
their shoulder so they keep tripping
over logs and [__] right so eventually
the [__] do with the hatchet walks
them down and puts them out of their
misery that's what that's what [__]
the Warriors did to Oklahoma no to you
such as was that too sophisticated for
you you know I gotta tell you watching
the Warriors come back against Oklahoma
was like watching Friday the 13th part 3
og he's Tom so I've seen a bunch of
teams do that be better than the other
team they just didn't know how to
[__] win and then what happens is as
a sports fan you get to watch them learn
how to win you get to launch amateur as
a [__] Pig that's what you get to
watch unless the best guy goes you know
what I don't feel like learning that's
going to go join the team that came back
and kicked our ass I mean
can you imagine if movies will like that
alright there's like the nerd getting
beat up by the bully you know there's
like five nerds getting beat up by these
five bullies right it's five on five
right and then the third act is not the
[__] nerds figure out how to beat
down the bullies one of the nerds joins
the other bullies and then helps them go
back and beat up all his friends I mean
granted I guess that kind of be funny if
you're a sick [__] like me but at the
end of the day that kind of movie is
that well maybe Act two was that he goes
to [__] Golden State in the nectaries
he comes back and he has one of those
LeBron James type movies I don't [__]
know all I know is that you know I kind
of got back into the NBA this year I
started watching the Celtics and that
type of [__] and there was a great
rivalry out west and now it's no more
did you hear what yeah barkbox thoughts
a great Boston me dude [__] chow
Spike Lee said [__] Kevin Durant's a
cheater not cheating like Tom Brady that
was [__] cheating like Kevin Durant
he's not on our team so I'll hold them
to the fist feet to the fire not
cheating like Jim Irsay
he said that yeah he's trying to cheat
his way to a championship he used the
wrong word but I understand what he's
saying he's just he's just a [__]
yeah he just he left the nerd table he's
he is going to the bully table and then
he's going to come back and beat up the
nerd and be like ooh look at me I'm a
tough guy over here is it amazing how
much taller Kevin Durant is than me and
I'm still given up [__] that's the
wonderful thing about podcasting is you
can [__] talk [__] within the safety
of your own living room alright whatever
I'm going to get off this [__] topic
but uh I did in fact to confirm Michael
Rapaport Real Housewife tweet by the way
is there anyone can somebody please
Photoshop him into one of those Real
Housewives [__] things we had a great
conversation laughing our balls off when
we came to an agreement in the end
of it and that Danny Ainge looking
[__] goes on the internet and he
hate tweets 180 letters are less about
me by the way I have to apologize for I
love my crap before I you know every
time I see him I would feel like this is
still last time I'm never going to see
him you know there's just something
about him even though he's younger than
me he just moves around like he's in his
80s I think he has that disease you
don't let disease Brad Pitt head in that
movie where he was like a [__] old
baby whatever the [__] happened I don't
know that's what he were remind no
listen I was just a fable right was it
called a fairy tale
whatever he [__] he's like that you
know you know like when a [__]
eight-year-old looks like they're 70
whatever that disease is called
I'm going to say George Mikan that's not
that wasn't the guy who was the guy who
played on the high OH state and went to
Portland that poor bastard the micro
fractures in his feet I think he's
playing to China now I'm thinking his
Haven Moses and I only play for the
Broncos in the 70s I want to say his
name was George wasn't it okay we got to
look this up now house state Ohio House
state Portland micro fraction might not
microbrewery get the [__] out here micro
micro breweries are the worst early all
right what's his name what's his name
Greg Oh Michael Rapaport has Greg Oden
disease it does and like Greg Oden he
got paid a ton of [__] money and he
didn't follow through he got paid that
the the national podcasting Association
drafted him number one to come on in to
the podcasting world to talk about
sports thinking that he was going to be
unfair now thinking that he was going to
be biased and fair I came to [__]
talk this morning oh my god I can't wait
to do his podcast again
you know who's kidding who were both a
couple of real housewives you know I
mean I think I'm slightly better looking
than him though slightly you know and a
little more mobile you know I think I
bring a lot more to a team I'm like
spike Owen right utility player him I
don't know what he is he's like a
[__] Rappaport's like a [__] you
know he's like that D H you know his
careers over you know he can't touch his
toes so they can't have him play first
base he just sits on the bench eating
sunflower seeds gets up three four times
a game squinting into the [__] Sun he
just swings for the fences grounds out
into a double-play kills the rally you
know but he's got such a big contract
they can't get rid of him he's like Greg
luzinski if you went on a diet
although no disrespect to Greg luzinski
I don't want the stuff I'm talking about
here Oh formula one right I needed to
apologize because when I would say when
I watched the Austrian Grand Prix that
it was like [__] days of stuff and I
said Lewis Hamilton was like the Tom
Cruise the up star I added completely
wrong and I want to thank everybody on
Twitter that set me straight so
eloquently hey fuckstick
I guess Lewis Hamilton he's but he's
he's won at three times he's 31 [__]
years old and he's already won the
Formula One Championship three times he
won in 2008 2014 and 2015 Nico Rosberg
has never won so the reality is is that
Nico was the Tom Cruise right and Lewis
Hamilton is the Val Kilmer he's the Ice
Man that's right i man I am dangerous
and then Lewis Hamilton clicks his teeth
together but no [__] reason right
they're all sweaty and [__]
I don't know all I know is the British
Grand Prix is is this [__] is this
Sunday and that dude toto I swear to god
that's his [__] nickname all I want
to do when I wake up in the morning not
see the team crash sat down with them it
was just like listen all right Roy stop
[__] driving into each other make
whatever the [__] you said I know where
he's from I think he just I think he's
from Austria who knows I'm new to this
sport I just like throwing up [__] as
fact you know what I mean and why would
I why would I actually waste the time to
read up on this sport when I can just
make big [__] statements and people on
Twitter will correct me anyways you know
then I don't have to look it up all I
got to do is just scroll you know so
these kids are so [__] dumb today no
they don't read books the way I used to
you know three hours in up 17 pages in
my [__] AEDs off the [__] shark
right sitting there reading about Tom
Sawyer you don't thinking about I don't
know what yeah the Queen Mary God knows
whatever was said in that [__] book
that made me think of something else
apples how's this some sort of arsenic
in there now how many apples would you
have to do to actually poison yourself
you know eat so many [__] apples
woody I think this arsenic of some [__]
you know the Apple some sort of poison I
can't remember what if you ate enough of
them right you'd actually die and then
somebody would actually get to say to
you gee you know an apple a day does in
fact keep the doctor away but you know
yeegh 42 of them you're going to [__]
die but you know what he died um anyways
let's let's read some of the [__]
horseshit here for this week let's read
some of the advertising shall we
is this it is just a simple safe
does that sound like bad food all right
no it isn't simple safe all right Alex
Hilux you're unique you don't waste you
don't walk like everyone else talk like
everyone else
stop Walker kick
it sounded like doing that Marine Corps
I'm gonna teach you how to walk talk to
Chad blocker yeah sorry very cool
alright your your unique everybody you
don't walk like everyone else talk like
everyone else or please like everyone
else
so why is your mattress your so why is
your mattresses so why is your mattress
how do you spell mattress well how do
you spell mistress so why is your
mattress one-size-fits-all gee I don't
know
I don't cuz you do [__] because it's
fit because the truly customized
mattress will cost you five or ten
thousand bucks ah
the reason who the [__] has the money to
do that they should get audited
immediately you know I was watching one
of those Barrett Jackson's one time and
they had one of those those GM that
parade a progress [__] elephant van
there somebody spent 4.1 million dollars
on that [__] thing and was excited
like they got a good deal you know I
mean that guy either needs to get
audited or he has his wife bound and
gagged in a [__] closet
how you pull the hey hey honey look what
I spent four million dollars on a giant
[__] toaster that you can drive what
do you mean why did I do that
oh because I liked I thought it was a
good deal [__] you lady right what are
these things called GM parade this is
still e Everton parade of progress nice
to know what these things were called
parade of progress image the GM future
liner look that [__] thing up I mean
granted it's kind of cool but it is it's
like an easy-bake oven that you can
drive and somebody paid 4.1 million
dollars for that [__] think you know
then all I said all I could think was
what was he doing in 2008 when they
[__] economy crashed other than doing
[__] cartwheels out the backdoor of
whatever [__] bank he worked at all
bill is that social commentary you
freckled [__] just shut up and read the
advertising all right up here
go HELOCs everybody helix I want to read
this like a [__] yoga instructor here
unique you don't walk like anyone else
talk like anyone else or sleep like
anyone else so why is your mattress
one-size-fits-all because they truly
customized mattress will cost you five
to ten thousand bucks and how many
starving children could that feed 4050
million for only half a cent a day
somehow you can give somebody three
square meals on Ethiopian Airlines
alright so it cost you five to ten
thousand bucks until now so go to HELOCs
leap com answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a 3d biomechanical model
of your body through the proper
proprietary algorithms they've developed
doesn't that sound like a bunch of
[__] Ginuwine proprietary algorithms
I can't say it so what's the good they
developed with the help of the world's
leading Aragon omics and biomechanics
experts the results the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on helix
customers hallux report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality and
for couples they customize each each
side of the mattress oh that's great
your mattress arrives at your door in
about a week and shipping is 100% free
that's why everyone from GQ magazine to
Forbes not just the same people you get
to the top of your bank and then all of
a sudden you like I don't have a yacht
and [__] wavy brown hair with a
[__] Rolex are all talking about
hellix sleep you have 100 nights to try
it out if you don't love it they'll pick
it up for free give you a 100% refund no
questions asked
go to hell you know what a lot of
homeless people going to be in a good
night's sleep then because there's no
[__] way you can resell that Kenya or
Kenya I don't [__] know all right
just dump it on a sidewalk go to helix
sweet calm slash burg get $50 off your
order that's helic sweet calm slash /
hey helix sleep calm / / alright and
lastly but
certainly not leastly ah what's our old
friends it recruiter are you hiring do
you know where to post your job to find
the best candidates posting your job at
one place isn't enough to find quality
candidates come on wake up you want to
find the perfect hire you need to post
your job to all the top job sites and
you can do it now all right with zip
Crudup comm you can post your job to 100
plus job sites including social media
networks like Facebook and Twitter all
with the single click
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip
Reuters easy to use interface no
juggling emails or calls to your office
quickly screen candidates rate them look
at the tips on her and hire the right
person fast
find out why zip recruiter has been used
by 800,000 businesses and right now
listeners contrives ever and recruit it
for free by going to zip recruiter comm
/ / that zip recruit accom / / one more
time go to zip dot-com / / alright there
we go there we go - the perfect place
that perfect place takes all right she
once again my my European tour but my
Yura
opinion [__] [__] tour I am
gonna [__] I am so excited about this
tour alright
I'm so excited I love going to Europe I
love being everything that they want me
to be okay I'm sorry I'm not going to be
fat on this one because I've been
hitting the elliptical there but I'm
going to be I'm going to go over there
right and I'm going to talk to them
about the finer points of Donald Trump
that's what I want to do especially in
Scotland where they had the nerve to
called our [__] orange headed [__] a
[__] orange headed [__] you got a
lot of [__] nerve Scott
call it an orange headed content or
enchanted [__] women why don't you look
around your country there's plenty of
orange headed [__] there all right we
have very few here in every once a while
they run for president when they're in
between seasons of their reality show
okay what's great about our country is
everybody truly does get a chance unlike
your countries I have no [__] idea
what's going on over there
evidently England decided to not be part
of the European Union is that what
happened I love how like as an American
I'm supposed to know this [__] a union
that I'm not into I understand what's
going on over there
the banks are sewing up all your [__]
countries it's like when you [__] buy
a co-op you know versus a condo you buy
a condo the person next to you can be a
[__] junkie who gives a [__] you
still got your condo but if you're in a
co-op Playoffs you're in a co-op this is
a deal what you read by an apartment
what you're doing is you're buying
shares in the building but now you're
tied in with the whole building so
basically if your neighbors enough of
your neighbors go bankrupt and the whole
the whole building goes under you lose
your shares and you either have to move
out of your apartment or you go back to
renting it and you're like wait a minute
I thought I'd bought it no no no sir
you bought shares in the building you
paid your way but these other [__] and
because they didn't you go down to the
bottom of the lagoon with them that to
me is what the European Union is right
and that's what banks want right they
just [__] bankrupt them and I don't
know what the [__] they do they play
that little [__] game they buy low
and then they [__] go I and I could
they'd pull the money out everybody
falls in their [__] ass and then they
got another castle you know I think that
that's how the economy works right and
it's all run by shapeshifters okay check
just [__] like that you know what I mean
especially when I'm in London and those
stupid [__] critics show up ah
[__] guys critics
what could worse there's nothing you can
do there's no show that you can have
that they're not going to rip the [__]
out of it I just [__] hilarious to me
it's like I don't need critic alright if
I wanted to feel bad about having a good
show I just call my mom don't [__]
need you to be doing her job you know
whatever
alright July 31st everybody Dublin
Ireland all right then August 1st I'm in
Belfast I've never been there
Belfast Ireland the [__] is Belfast UK
alright
Ireland I think it's about time England
got the [__] out of there she'd imagine
saying that is American seriously you
know is we're putting up Cheesecake
factories in the Middle East my August
1st Belfast
UK August 2nd I'm in Galway Ireland
which is way out on the west coast and
evidently the closest airport is like a
[__] hour away from it so I don't
understand what this is this seems like
should I ruin it and actually [__]
Google some pictures of it Galway
Ireland let's see we got here oh my god
Jesus cry I do it I know this is going
to be one of these [__] which is a
warlock one of those [__] movies safe
cities Harry Potter look at this [__]
place
oh my god I'm only spending a day there
wow look at the [__] castles holy
[__] now I'm going to drive in there do
the show and then I got to drive right
back so I can make my flight what a [__]
am I going did I [__] it up what am I
going next
alright I go to well then I fly to a
Bristol England and then Manchester
England the sober sophisticated
Manchester I'm thinking that's going to
be a nice mellow crowd
[__] loaded tix that's what I'm
anticipating in Manchester I anticipated
there going to be a bunch of [__]
lunatics which is which is fine by me I
I grew up Massachusetts you know London
England August 5th and August 6th with
the country critics August 7th I'll be
in Amsterdam and then August 8th I will
be in Edinburgh for two shows all right
so we got a Late Show - okay then I got
a couple days off well be hanging out
with other orange headed [__] like
myself and then August 11th in Germany
Cologne Germany bodywash Germany then
August 12th I'm in Antwerp Belgium I'll
look at this August 27th I'm in Reno
Reno Nevada Reno Nevada and at that
point we will be only a couple of months
away from that [__] kitchen TV
square-headed [__] safe crazy eyed
smiling psycho from becoming the next
[__] President of the United States
oh that's going to be a rough one
watching all these ladies saying how
[__] what an important day it is for
women I guess it will be because a woman
be elected president is just my
prediction here all right but uh Jesus
Christ couldn't we have gotten one that
didn't have 58 pending [__] felonies
that's not a red flag anybody you know
better what are you gonna do those are
our choices I don't know why a [__]
maniac who you know doesn't know how to
use email properly you know sending out
secrets to a friend and then some
[__] guy who's uh I don't know who
really should just be a carnival barker
I feel like Trump should just be
standing next to some impossible game to
win talking about how it's the greatest
game ever
you know cuz he hits on underage chicks
that's just that's just the opinions of
somebody who can't pronounce words
while he reads out loud what do you so
what'd he say there Clio that's the
that's the podcast here for this dis
Thursday afternoon so I you know what
somebody please send me a [__]
whatever a photoshopped picture of
[__] Rappaport's face on dannyandjess
body when he played for the Celtics I
really want to see that too you can do
whatever the [__] you want to do with my
head you know I don't give a [__] that's
it all right I got to go hit the
elliptical so I'm not a [__] fat [__]
at the end of this writing season here
congratulations to Kevin Durant on your
next when you're doing your first
championship ring you know I want to put
together a stand-up tour like that
you know what I mean I want to join like
the like if louis c.k and dave shipped
dave chappelle would do it like a
stand-up tour I'd somehow like I don't
know I don't know I do like their next
stand-up specials I'll splice part of my
hour in there I can get credit all right
that's it
you guys have a great weekend your
country and I love posse on Monday yes
enjoy the music and another half hour
Monday morning process back for
yesteryear
[Music]
like out of bed Rosie but my brain is we
robbed me in fantasy III you passed me
by my soul
well I love
without a stash hey what's going on
Silva and this is the Monday morning
podcast that I'm actually doing from my
home phone rather than my cell phone I
finally figured out how to call in this
myspace
[__] Jesus Christ I'm having one of
those weeks all right I just talk I just
babbles to twelve minutes and decided
that I didn't like it and now I have to
[__] start all over again I don't
want to do this I don't to do this do
you think I want to do this I don't want
to [__] do this you know sometimes in
life you got to do what you got yeah oh
yeah he's [__] podcast man you know
long these things take
some weeks I get on here you know I just
babbled it's [__] gold just half hour
just running my goddamn mouth I don't
you have to think and then there's other
times it's it's just it's like shoveling
wet snow and you know what I'm [__]
sticking this one out because I'm not
going to start over again a sometimes
you know what sometimes you just not
that funny
you [__] mine's broken up or whatever
I don't know let's just get down to
goddamn brass tacks here and I'll let
you know what I got going on all right
my name is dobro this is my myspace page
this is my Monday morning podcast I do
one of these every goddamn week okay try
to get people a nice laugh to start off
their [__] weeks and we start off in
a good mood and then I end up getting
frustrated with my own ineptness and
then I end up just [__] I don't know
I end up snapping and I say [__] a lot
all right and okay let's get on with
people ask me questions I answer them I
mean I'm just you know I'm just blowing
through this just blowing through the
explanations I usually take my time and
explain this you know what this is like
either like break your arm or something
and you go to school the next day
instance the first kid goes hey man what
happened to your arm right and you give
them every last [__] detail okay but
then by this time you've told the
[__] story to like the 12th person by
the time the 13th person comes up to you
you like I [__] fell down all right
with the [__]
happened you know that's the mindset of
men right now as I do this podcast
that's just blowing 12 minutes a Verizon
time on my home phone all right here we
go let's get down with this [__] here
lets kids get on with it I put up a new
video because I'm desperately trying to
get myself to become part of the new
millennium
it's right underneath the podcast if you
look there you'll see a very blurry very
blurry me and a Winnipeg Jets shirt by
the way because I'm old school old
school hockey that's me at the punchline
in Atlanta and before you watch the
video I just want to give you a little
backstory what happened eventually was
Thursday night and a couple weeks ago
and it's one of my favorite clubs now I
was just having one of these awesome
sets where I was I was really open and
free and everything was just flowing as
opposed to this podcast which feels very
arduous very work like that I used that
word correctly - [__] is Questlove learn
those [__] lime green pants I just
realized that anyways I was having one
of these uh one of these just you know
really open just great sets and I was
about 12 minutes in and everybody was
laughing ever he's having a good time I
was having a good time but for some
reason there was this lady in the crowd
and it wasn't enough that she felt my
jokes were funny she was somehow
agreeing with the things that I was
saying onstage
so rather than laughing at the end of
every joke you know when the punchline
came out instead of laughing she would
just yell out thank you after every joke
you know the rest of crowd was boobie
laughing and then I would just hear this
woman's voice over everybody dang yo so
this video picks up about 12 minutes
into my set
she's already yelled thank you like
[__] 12 times and I feel annoying that
is with me saying that to you just
imagine being on stage trying to keep
the crowd trying to keep the [__]
plate spinning and somebody keeps
yelling that [__] out so she yells it
out for I guess basically the sixth time
and that's when I finally snapped but I
snapped in a good way I was proud of
myself I didn't chop her head off and be
overly mean
kind of mean but it was definitely funny
and and fun like you guys know I'm gonna
start taping all my sets because uh you
know I riffle app and I end up you know
missing a lot of good lines that I could
keep in my ACK and also random [__]
happens and I'm going to start posting
some of the random [__] that happens up
here unless people really start to enjoy
these and then they come up to my shows
and then they deliberately try to yell
out something which is always the risk
of it but basically I like doing this
kind of thing because I want to give you
guys some new some new laughs without
having to burn any material you know
what I mean I mean I'm not threatened
Reznor here I can't just give away my
new hour for free you know like he can't
I'm jealous of musicians right they can
just [__] put the goddamn music out
for free now and then everybody comes to
their shows and when they they know all
the words they get to sing along so it's
different then you can go you know we're
going to break down Detroit going to
break it down here writing slows the
[__] song down and then everybody do
whatever brings the music level down and
everybody sings along can't do that with
jokes maybe if I started singing my
jokes maybe I'll do that I'll come with
a [__] ukulele onstage you know but I
could [__] sing
that's why guitar acts blow up man
telling [__] telling you I heard
about some kid in Massachusetts whose
kid he's been putting funny songs up on
YouTube for the last year and he just
sold out the comedy connection it's like
17 [__] years old you know lungs took
me to sell out economy connection 15
[__] years telling jokes you know why
cuz I don't sing
why would you sing my goddamn jokes
what's the deal with labs everybody if I
would just do that I would just do that
I don't know you know I don't know what
would happen you know something you
always want to thank you know if I just
did that then I'd be here
you never think of all the failed guitar
acts you know the ones that you guys
don't see you just see the successful
ones you know the ones with their half
hour specials the ones selling out
theaters alright you don't see the ones
that
open for me when I go to Portland Oregon
at least when I did back in the day way
back in the day 10 years ago
play a club called Harvey's all I
remember was the walls were green and
the guy used to he used to give the
whole show away which basically he would
have telemarketers call people up and
just be like hey guess what you've won
tickets to what you want for free
tickets to a comedy show and the people
be like holy [__] how the [__] did I win
those I didn't even enter the contest
you know well you won them because
comedy was not selling well 10 years ago
so they used to give a basically they've
give away the show you've walked into
this [__] place
it'd be a Tuesday you know I come
moseyin and I'm thinking alright so
Tuesday it'll be half full
no knows who the [__] I am I lean on the
mic stand I'll lift I'll get some new
jokes and you would walk in there and
you would think that Springsteen was
going to come on it was jam-packed 400
[__] drunk ass people who didn't know
me and did not give a [__] whether the
show was good or not
really because they already felt like
they'd already want they got free
tickets so you would go up there and it
would just be it'd be a [__] zoo it
would be an absolute zoo and a lot of
lumberjack that that was a vibe I got
you know Oregon has a lot of trees and
you'd be down there in Portland and
you'd be thinking alright it's very
crunchy very sort of progressive but you
know those [__] don't come out to show
the Lumberjacks would come up maybe
screaming and yelling and eating burgers
that would have fried eggs on the top of
them and and it sucked and not even what
I'm talking about that already forgot i
spaced halfway through that [__]
story because because that's the mindset
I'm in this week I got a zillion [__]
things I got to take care of because I'm
on my way to Pittsburgh this week and
I'm flying in a day early to do I'm
doing a lot of radio this week because
I'm going to try to sell that [__]
place out I want to be on W D de who's
Randy Bowman this week and if I had any
[__] brains I would have looked that
up and getting a better oh it's 100
point something I think
if you live in Pittsburgh you can listen
to me and I'll be the other so you
listen to me in the morning Wednesday
morning Thursday morning and Friday
morning and then you come out on the
weekend you check out my show just a
love of God just come up to my goddamn
okay enough [__] that I want to tell
you please I don't want to stand there
alone okay that that mall is the most
depressing [__] mall in America for
those of you who've never been to it
the Pittsburgh Improv is in a mall
called the stacks why do they call it
the stacks basically because I guess the
mall used to be a steel mill okay when
we used to have industry in this country
before they started telling us that
everything was too expensive to make in
this country so they had to you know
ship it to a third-world country and
have some eight-year-old kid kid make
[__] spittoons or whatever the [__]
it is you making a goddamn steel steel
mill right rather than being like now
all Americans are involved with unions
and they want health insurance and they
want to get paid for their work they
just say they just [__] picked up and
left but this is what they did they
knocked down the factory but they they
kept the stacks just to remind you that
that people you know there's this
reminded me my name is poltergeist you
know you move the headstones but you
didn't move the bodies why that's what
they did it that mall they must a
factory but they left the smokestacks
that's what they did to remind you that
hardworking Americans used to have jobs
there and they could support their
families and they made [__] out of steel
that other Americans would then buy okay
and the dollar was worth something but
they got rid of all that they shipped it
somewhere else and in its wake they left
[__] Cheesecake factories lucky jeans
and the [__] Cold Stone Creamery but
in tribute to all those people that they
[__] over
they left the chimneys isn't that nice
and a little nod to the past
and now they're [__] kids what are
they doing one day where do they work
you ever notice that when you meet
people and they come up here you ask
them what the [__] they do you don't you
don't even know what it is what do you
do I work in a steel mill okay you work
in a mill there's steel there and you
work there so you work with steel in a
mill I get that I understand what that
job is what do you do I'm the milkman
okay you're a man there's milk and you
[__] deliver it man
you're the milkman I get it I [__]
get it do you realize how many jobs
there are that people actually
understand what the [__] it is you do
now there's very few left I'm a mailman
I'm a man I deliver mail I'm the [__]
mailman back then they was simple simple
[__] names
all right I'm a silversmith all right
Smith meaning like to hit with a hammer
like smite and I'll duel with silver a
[__] silversmith all right there
wasn't any the the regional director of
the [__] you know so I I can't even I
can't even give you an example of
somebody's job I'm trying to think of
the all these computer I sit and can get
cubicle and make somebody else's dream
happen I'm telling you right now man
just sitting in a [__] cubicle just
do something rebellious today just take
one of the screws out of your fake I
don't really have an office wall that
they put in front of you to make you
feel like you have half an office but
the reality is they don't want you
looking at other people you know I think
I've talked about this before you guys
ever see that movie the apartment
starring Jack Lemmon if you see the
beginning of that movie that's what the
cubicle area used to look like you still
had a sea of people you know slugging
away looking like a bunch of goddamn
salmon swimming upstream with [__]
typewriters in front of them but they
didn't have walls around them like they
were on punishment you know you could
look at the person next to you shoot the
[__] but then somewhere along the line
they like know that they're [__]
talking we can't have them looking at
themselves they're literally treating
you like children I said I don't want
just [__] it just blows my mind
I mean III I'd rather sell drugs alright
so anyways this is the yeah this is the
Monday morning podcast and people send
me question if you new to my page if you
haven't defected to [__] Facebook
like the [__] that you are you know I
mean a lot of these people go into
Facebook now like like the same herd of
[__] that went from Friendster to
MySpace isn't isn't going to you know
they're not going to eventually end up
over there like there's not going to be
much of spam about ringtones and a bunch
of [__] with their butt cracks and
their titties hanging out you know
sending you generic emails trying to
make it seem like they didn't send it to
everybody else but you realize that they
did because rather than calling you by
your name it just says hey you love your
page by the way I'm the [__] Nokia
phone [__] of the month or whatever the
hell they're you know all those stupid
beauty contest things that they go to
win I'm sticking it out here man all
right and all you guys are all going
over the Facebook you know what you like
you like that you ever see that movie
the Titanic whereas those guys you know
who [__] jump in into the rafts all
by themselves those selfish sons of
[__] we're actually smart who listen
to that voice that says I need to
[__] survive well maybe they are
smart then maybe they realize that my
space may be my space is a sinking ship
you know I don't know they'd be actually
kind of funny not wouldn't because
they've already made their money off it
Rupert Murdoch Rd brought about this
thing made a billion dollars already
[__] [__]
alright I answer questions here I'm
really just babbling to answer questions
here every week people send me questions
I try to answer them to the best of my
ability and here we go here's the other
podcast question for the week
oh i'm by the way when you watch my
video could you please send me a comment
well if you liked it or whatever because
that's like a new thing that i really
want to start doing just putting some
random moments up there like that so let
me let me know let me know what you
think okay question number one
bill which one was better Mike Richter's
insane safe against Clavell DRA that's
how you saying Pavel Bure never know how
to say these Russian guys names his
insane save against his penalty shot
or Patrick law Mike Vernon going at its
center ice I'm definitely going to say
Mike Richter just because uh that would
that was one of the best years ever in
hockey those like 2004 when the Red Sox
finally wanted to watch the Rangers
finally when the cup and everybody go
crazy that was just an amazing moment
and to Patrick why am i burning thin you
know it was it you know it was a great
fight it's great to see Patrick wall
who's but you know Ted Owens for the
Stanley Cup and I remember watching that
in 1994 and watching the Rangers win and
I remember thinking clearly that's what
it's going to be like when the Red Sox
that they ever get their heads out of
their asses and they finally [__] win
one that that's going to be what it's
like so I was living vicariously and for
some reason I didn't hate the Rangers
for the simple fact that I was not old
enough when the Rangers last time the
Rangers Bruins rivalry was great which
was back in the 70s I was still just a
just a little lad for the big mop a
[__] red hair lookin like that dude
Joey on a family affair
alright and that's why I became a
comedian because that's who the [__] I
look like and I got the [__] kicked out
of me
alright question number two bill how the
hell does Paris Hilton keep getting
movie roles well I actually thought
about this one and I think the reason
that she keeps getting movie roles is
because not to be crude but she's not
afraid to show the clamp you know and I
think you know I think that's how that's
how you got to do it sometimes as a
woman you got you got it just every once
in a while you just got to take your
[__] out you know and I don't think
there's anything wrong with that Sharon
Stone did it Sharon Stone was you know
meandering around all these [__]
b-movie she you know she had
we decent role in some sort of
Schwarzenegger movie but it wasn't until
she showed the clam that people you know
sat up and took notice
next we know she's in that movie Casino
and delivered one of the best
performances III thought she should was
she nominated for an Oscar she should
have won one that year but that's when
showing the clam kind of hurt her
because all the other women resented her
you know what I mean they thought that
she was a [__] rather than she did what
she had to do and I don't understand
where women get upset when they're like
you know you're treating me like a you
know like a sexual object and it's like
you are a sexual object you know what I
mean that's like yeah I'm like oh you
just [__] using me cuz I can pick up
heavy [__] I can't pick up hit I mean
that extra heavy [__] but heavier [__]
cuz I'm a guy you know that's where
Hillary Clinton [__] up her campaign
when she [__] put on the pantsuit you
know she should have sexed it up a
little vamp it up God gave you titties
use them show no cleavage you know to me
that's what she should have done and
people do you know if you think that's
fella that's stupid you know guys don't
get elected because of their brains Bill
Clinton got elected because he played
the saxophone on [__] Arsenio Hall
and when our sitio came in to do the
black handshake somehow Bill Clinton was
able to do it without [__] breaking
his wrist and I think that right there
was when was when that was the turning
of it what else did he do we did sat
there smiling with his mouth open going
change America wants change didn't say
anything he played the [__] saxophone
so if you're a woman you know show a
little titty you're a little piggy
that's all that's all I could tell you
oh god I'm so ignorant all right
question number three
bill but but I put out what the [__] is
this one all right thanks for answering
my questions or this is an up-and-coming
comedian I competed in a funniest person
contest in a city that I will not I'm
not going to name because I don't get
this person
just in case one of my 14 listeners is
the club owner of that anyways the owner
said that he would not hire any of the
comedians to work for any of the clubs
because we were too vulgar the crazy
thing is I noticed that it was an older
crowd but I was being stubborn and
decided to do my normal routine which is
some dirty jokes in your opinion do you
think you're selling out if you adjust
your comedic style to get into the big
corporate clubs okay all right I know
what you're saying here I've done the
same thing
I've looked out the crowd going okay
this is what I want to talk about you
look at them you judge them and you go
well I'm going to be eating my balls at
least 40% of my set if I stick with what
I want to do and yeah when you 100%
adjust your act you yeah you definitely
yeah you feel dirty you know not nothing
not to use upon there but yeah you don't
feel good but it isn't a hundred percent
selling out if you know I don't know
it's one of those weird things where
it's your own judgment call you know
what I mean because I used to do those
macca things so for those of you who
aren't comedians here they have these
things every year these these national
showcases for college gigs and when I
used to showcase for them I would go up
and I would just do my act you know and
I remember one year something that was
going on in my act was the first time I
got you know an HIV test and I was
talking about the fear of it which is
and it's really not a joke that you want
to do one a college showcase you just
want to do you happy [__] and I didn't I
was like [__] dead man I'm [__]
selling out so I went up there and I did
my [__] and you know what I got zero
schools and I just got people they kept
coming up to me going we think you're
hilarious you know they kept getting the
whole world it was up to me I booked you
but I can't because of blah blah blah
blah blah and what I learned was
sometimes you got to play the game a
little bit so what I would then do was I
would go up after that I would go up
into a squeaky-clean set
then I would book the colleges and then
when I went to colleges I would actually
then do my act and then do the [__] that
I wanted to talk about so in a weird way
I actually want because I got the money
and I still got to do what I wanted to
do and I got people to hear the material
more people to hear the material that I
wanted them to hear I just had to be a
kind of wore myself out you know I had
to put on the tuxedo for like [__]
five six minutes Jesus you just brought
up a really bad [__] memory no but
dude I would say you know on your way up
yeah nobody wants you know a lot of
headliners don't want to go on in front
of a guy who kills and they also don't
wanna go on in front of a guy who's you
know if you if you're being a little
dirty that gives them an excuse to kind
of be like not just say that I can't
follow this guy they'll be like oh he's
just being dirty
so yeah play the game a little bit you
know you play the game a little bit and
then as people get to know who you are
you get way more leeway and eventually
you get to do you thing you know what I
mean it's one of those things you got to
be like a tree you know bend but don't
break you know I don't know do whatever
the [__] you want to do but you know I
don't watch my two cents and I'm [__]
oh I have no confidence my goddamn
opinion so no no you know ye people ask
me questions alright question number
four bill have you been approached about
doing any shows since your skips on
Chappelle yeah pitch one every year and
I try to get them on TV but for those of
you who always ask me how come you don't
have your own TV show because it's
really hard it's all I can tell you okay
it's very hard to get a show on TV
because believe it or not a lot of
people want to get a show on television
because you can make a lot of money so I
keep getting closer keep getting closer
hey Bill what do you think about Shaq's
rap about Kobe who was the bigger d-bag
in this never-ending saga
I think Shaq was just [__] around I
thought he was joking but he wasn't
joking but he was joking you don't I
mean I mean if somebody gets arrested
for a potential rape and they bring my
name up during it
you know I think I have the license to
give him [__] for a while and if I'm in
a club and I want to [__] make fun of
him a little bit yeah I don't know I
just looked the checks face I thought he
was clearly joking around and it was so
over the top Kobe had it how's my ass
taste I mean I don't know how does it
taste Scheck I don't know like you've
been running full court to last 15 years
for the disgusting question all right ah
number five we've got a lot of questions
this week and we'll try to blow through
them um well went to the Tempe improv
saw this comic he was good but the
opening act was killing it he was so
funny do you ever get worried to stress
that your opener is going to be more
funny than you is there any sort of
process you go through picking your
opener am I worried about them being
more funny well no I'm not their [__]
middle axe for a reason all right if you
can't follow a middle rack then you're
not a headliner I've definitely had some
funny guys on in front of me but I think
that's a good thing you know I mean you
don't to be sparring with somebody who
sucks because then you're going to end
up sucking so I believe in going out
with hitman you know bringing in a
middle act that's you know funny in an
original and that's my process to
picking an opener I use Joe DeRosa Kevin
Shay I'm going to be using this guy Todd
Rex up in San Francisco these guys Todd
Rex you know in particular no disrespect
to those other two [__] but he really
[__] kills so I let my work cut out
for me that week brother yeah I don't
wanna do that guy I don't want to have
some guy who just goes up there with
like a lampshade on his head and stinks
wow these are a lot of questions here is
your podcast getting too long all right
April I got a question for your podcast
you ever get a chance to meet George
Carlin unfortunately no I didn't I was
supposed to meet him
when was it February of March right
before he did is specially supposed to
be doing the comedy magic club down on
Hermosa Beach and I just done a spot
down there and they said hey he's coming
in whatever on a Wednesday or a Tuesday
he can come down watch the show and he
can meet him after
words and it was going to be a dream
come true but he ended up getting sick
obviously his health was failing and he
ended up cancelling so I never got a
chance to meet him but I did get a
chance to see him and he absolutely blew
me away
and it was actually with a long sigh was
like 20 years ago before I was even
doing comedy and I did at least get the
same because I never got to see Pryor so
at least I can say that I saw and with
him passing is really making me want to
go see Don Rickles because you know that
guy's in his 80s and he's still [__]
hilarious and I don't know he should you
know the comedian I think anybody likes
comedy should see those guys so no I did
not get a chance to meet him but I did
get to see him in person and obviously
as you can see on my page he was a huge
influence on me obviously right all
right what are we doing here
two more questions and then I'm going to
wrap this [__] thing up number seven
bill do you okay I guess you got it
[__] asked advice here on dating you
know I'm [__] not married at 40 and
somebody's asking me advice on
relationships okay you really need to
consider your sources here all right
that's like once you go ask somebody on
heroin you think math is bad you know
hey man if you like doing it you should
so I can do it alright here we go
bill do you think a person deserves more
than one date to determine if there is
chemistry I recently went out on a date
with a guy turns out I wasn't my type
well there's your answer right there but
he had a nice personality but I feel you
should know you should feel something
immediately you're answering your
questions it's not like he was my friend
to begin with or will be my friend
that'll have time to grow on me I feel
very mean and superficial uh-oh okay
there you go right there
there's your first mistake with dating
when you date you have to be
unbelievably selfish unbelievably
selfish are you not going to get what
you want and it's not even being selfish
because if you settle for something that
you don't want you're not going to be
happy okay and then you're going to make
the other person miserable and that's
not fair to the other
person so [__] that guy alright [__] him
man is a nice personality hook him up
with another one of your friends say hey
I met a guy that I'm not into but he has
a nice personality you know what I mean
that's like that's like watching a TV
show that you don't enjoy but you really
like the look of it the end of it you
don't like the [__] show so how long
are you gonna be interested you know as
you know no psycho friends I used to
watch friends when I lived in New York
City I was like God look at that
apartment wish I had a [__] huge
apartment like that but I hated the
[__] show so at the end of the day I
didn't watch the show how long can you
look at the couch alright question
number eight this is a final question
bill why while this is a cheesy question
I am a chef so I always ask and so I
always ask and I think the answer says a
lot what is your favorite food
slash restaurant what is my favorite
food I like steak um's and I really like
that Steak and Shake you know it's got
two things I really enjoy red meat and
shakes now I'm really I don't I like
everything I would say Italian I think
Italians make the best food hands-down
and it's absolutely delish and you know
the olive oil and just you know you know
what I love about Italians who really
know how to cook they they know how to
add stuff like they don't over like I'll
explain it like whatever they add
enhances the dish it doesn't overpower
you know what I mean
like take like the art of making pizza
somewhere along the line the cheese on
the pizza rather than enhancing the
taste of the sauce the cheese became the
focal point okay okay I can't explain it
like it became to lead the movie when it
was actually you know the guy who had
two lines in the mood it's like oh look
Pizza Hut they got it all over they got
it in the crust they got it everywhere
he's just eating a big brick of cheese
and it tastes like [__] [__] and you
can't move your bowels afterwards
that I like Italian food I like the
olive oil that they cook with I just you
know it's very clean
you know you drink that you know it's
sip of wine as long as you don't eat
like like you're going to the [__]
Olive Garden
you just feel great you take your time
the whole thing that's what I like about
Italian food and restaurants like the
whole thing the lighting the ambiance
everything so anyways with that my my
favorite restaurant when I was in New
York was I used to really like lupa that
was my favorite one the Mario Batali one
and out here in LA one of the best ones
I went to I have been to a lot out here
I went to Malta which is a another Mario
Batali one but I'm sort of like a hacky
restaurant guy where if they have a show
on the Food Network I end up going to it
like you know that you know that blonde
guy who wears the sunglasses backwards
on his head he's actually a favorite
chef of joe de Rosas
I forget his [__] name but he just
goes around to diners and that type of
[__] and I ate his restaurant in
Sacramento and it was one of the worst
[__] things I ever went to he
actually had I think I talked about it
he had he had this sushi roll that had
pork and french fries in it with some
sort of barbecue sauce and it wasn't
rice I don't know what it was it was
some sort of pasty thing it was
absolutely [__] disgusting and it's
in Sacramento don't go to it and there
you go
that's the end of the [__] podcast
questions I think that's it I think
that's it for the week also I trashed
Best Buy last week said I was going to
go there anymore because they had that
15% restocking fee somebody sent me an
email about that that if you buy
something there and you don't like it
you bring it back they still charge you
15% of it to just stick it back on the
shelf so some Best Buy person wrote
where I work at Best Buy and trust me
it's necessary they do it mainly on
computers because when we sell one we
only make about 20 bucks in profit
really is that how you keep that big
store open you make $20 on each laptop I
don't buy that
and when someone decides to return it if
we have to sell it for below cost no you
don't I've never gone into Best Buy and
seen a TV or anything that says
everything there is full price what are
you talking about I don't know I'm going
to give you the better for the den I'm
not gonna give you the benefit is out
because Best Buy let's say it's you sir
who wrote this [__] thing but you work
for an evil [__] place that put
mom-and-pop [__] places out of
business okay back in the day when you
return something they just returned it
they put it back in the [__] box and
they stuck it on the shelf they didn't
charge you 15 percent okay that's one of
those exploiting new revenue streams new
way to come up with extra money to [__]
the customer I firmly believe that I've
been invest I've shot them Best Buy I've
never seen any you CDs any used
computers everything is brand-new ok so
maybe you got to clarify that is there
some sort of off the rack Best Buy thing
down the street
Best Buy part two I have no idea but I'm
still saying [__] Best Buy so why don't
you write me a follow-up ok I know it's
a bit of a [__] there so explain it
further because I don't get it so
anyways that's the podcast for the week
thanks to everybody who sent me in all
the goddamn questions and what am I
going to say here yeah I'm going to be
at the The Improv in Pittsburgh this
week for the love of God please come out
I got a brand new hour that I'm really
proud of and it's really depressing to
be at that goddamn mall with the stacks
you know the poltergeist acts this
[__] chimneys there ok I'm going to
the Pirates game Wednesday night all
right it'll be me and 30 other [__]
people there so you'll be able to see me
come up to come up to me and say what's
up Wednesday night against the Astros
further news I'll be in the Comedy Works
in Denver in the first week of August
and what else I got the Improv in Miami
I got a bunch of gigs coming up I have
an upcoming tour an upcoming hour
special coming out August 23rd on Comedy
Central fat half a brain I would have
said that at the beginning of this
podcast my new CD
coming out August 3rd and I think that's
it please keep the questions coming and
and that is it thanks for listening to
the podcast you guys have yourself a
great week alright take it easy
[Music]
my knees
oh you gotta gotta take it
my wiener
don't
[Music]
- politely well I got everything I need
I'll make my diesel it take away my
safety if it'll say the other service we
do but I'm all pumped to do is living on
y'all y'all out it all back periodic
over microphone a little take it now the
days are done someone wrong
[Music]
Blanca tuneups is God and me
um
[Music]
you know
so where it make the
my
[Music]
now [__]